with the leaders European leaders a
debate an open debate
on our future
but today is a very difficult day for
everyone in Europe yeah in criminal
yesterday a criminal killed three
European citizens and wounded 12
European citizens in the center of the
city of Strasbourg the city is the seat
of the European Parliament a city which
symbolizes peace on the border between
France and Germany this was a criminal
attack against peace democracy and our
way of life we must react by doing
exactly the opposite of those who wish
to harm democracy we must press ahead we
must not change a habit that's why last
night we continued to work in the
plenary we completed our business at
midnight today we're here to continue
[Applause]
pastula
[ __ ] the reason for that is that the
strength of freedom and democracy win
out against the violence of crime and
terrorism we are on the side of the
victims families last night I received a
message of solidarity to the European
Parliament from the president of France
mr. McCollum I received a number of
phone calls from my senior officials in
the European institutions and
organizations Parliament is at the heart
of democracy as I was saying and we
defend democracy by our work yesterday
we debated terrorism today we will
taking the vote on a motion for a
resolution regarding the work of the
Committee on terrorism at 12:00 noon I
will ask you to observe a minute's
silence in solidarity with the victims
unfortunately some of the injured
patients in hospital are still in a
critical condition which is why we are
standing side by side with France a
country which has suffered a number of
attacks following Paris and other cities
in in France now Strasbourg has been hit
but we wish to react as European
citizens representing 500 million
Europeans
as we debate Europe of course Europe
needs to change but we cannot destroy it
this is the only way we can show
strength in Europe win over violence and
you have the floor for this important
debate
[Applause]
the appraiser to ever Canole President
of the European Parliament's members of
the European Parliament in English his
terms the terrorist attack that took
place yesterday here is the last book I
express my deepest sympathy and
condolences to the families and wish a
speedy and full recovery to those who
were injured
Terri's constitute one of the more
serious threats to the peace and
security of our union we shall not allow
fear and terror to prevail instead we
shall remain united in enhancing our
efforts to eliminate this phenomenon
and it is a high honor for me
tres the plenary session of the European
Parliament in the presence of the
presidents of the political institutions
before the European citizens and to have
the opportunity to present the thoughts
my ideas but most of all my vision for
the future of the Union
yeah righto curious ki kiri ladies and
gentlemen I am fully aware that I am
addressing the institution which is a
symbol if you will of our very heart of
unity and democracy in Europe the
timeless principles and values that have
been pervading the development of the
large common European family are
represented in that institution as
European Parliament you are one of the
basic pillars to safeguard the
democratic functions of the European
Union and this is why your role is and
will continue to remain decisive ladies
and gentlemen for Cyprus and its people
the accession of Cyprus to the EU in
2004 was really the capping stone of our
European orientation and an identity
that goes back millions of years it was
very strongly supported by the Cypriot
people not only because it has seen as a
source of stability and prosperity but
also as a potential catalyst in our
ongoing efforts for renewed
reunification and consolidation of
security and peace in our country I wish
to stress that in 2004 Greek Cypriots
and Turkish Cypriots identified their
own future with the future of Europe
with the conviction that very soon the
same conditions of normality peace and
security of the Member States would also
prevail in our country mr. president
ladies and gentlemen today is Europe
emerged from the horror of two world
wars as a result of collective
consciousness and responsibility of
courageous leaders who believed in
cooperation and unity their aim was to
first of all work together in the
economic sphere but also to safeguard
human rights the rule of law prosperity
the security and safety of citizens
through economic unification and the
establishment of the Four Freedoms now
to achieve those goals with hard work
collective work Europe has really stands
out as the most remarkable model of
peace and prosperity in modern history
and this is a model that we must
preserve but also strengthen and we are
very very concerned as we witness the
latest trends and developments which are
shaking this unity which has been with
us for so many years these developments
and trends such as the exit of a member
state from the European Union the
closing of borders in violation of the
Schengen treaty the re-emergence of
nationalistic trends the erosion of the
union's role through this rise of
populism and an arbitrary application of
the principle of solidarity the acute
rise in the phenomenon of terrorism as
we unfortunately witnessed yesterday
unfortunately on matters we must reflect
upon deeply these are phenomena that we
need to tackle collectively to protect
the geographical and political and
economic unity that is to say the
European integration that we have worked
so hard to achieve
mr. president ladies and gentlemen
President Juncker
presented an ambitious work program for
the current Commission's term of office
with a view to the next European
elections which are looming Cyprus being
a staunch advocate of a stronger more
powerful more democratic and more united
Europe has been and continues to be
committed to implementing this program
within that framework the consultations
underway have to do with our future the
of Europe and an excellent opportunity
to listen to civil society so that we
are better able to assess how effective
our policies are and to redefine them in
order to ensure that they are better
targeted to be beneficial to citizens we
need to listen to the citizens in order
to understand the underlying causes of
the abrasion and as expressed through
the broad abstention from the European
elections and we need to try and
understand the reasons behind this gap
and crisis in confidence and trust
ladies and gentlemen the consultations
for the future of European all member
states must be based in my view on the
following questions what your up do we
want and what are the lessons we can
draw from the course of Europe so far
what needs to be improved and how can it
be done how close are we to our citizens
what are the causes behind the rise in
nationalist and populist movements and
how might we deal with this phenomenon
how are the increasing social and
economic equality within Europe to be
tackled in my view it is now urgently
essential that we refined clear
responses to these questions within the
framework of self-criticism reflection
and that we realize where we failed and
where we can do better so that people in
Europe citizens can once again trust the
Union and its institutions
so they can feel safe again in the
conviction that challenges are being met
and feel the positive impact on their
daily lives of the common policies of
the European Union in such areas as
health the environment working
conditions and these are areas which
affect citizens everyday life and
prosperity mr. president the European
Union without a doubt is a mosaic of
nations and peoples and its beauty and
value is derived from that composition
and diversity and each piece has its own
worth just as it has its own specific
features the most sake remains however
imperfect when just a small piece is
even missing and therefore the power and
the worth lie in the composition and
unity of that mosaic and this is where
we base our cooperation on unity and
solidarity ladies and gentlemen in 2013
when I took over the presidency of
Cyprus
I found myself facing painful dilemmas
Cyprus was facing a severe economic
crisis which on the basis of the size
and the nature of its economy affected a
large majority of its citizens in a very
negative way
it meant that necessary but difficult
decisions had to be taken with decisive
actions and measures and with the
support of the Society of Cyprus which
at the time was having to face the
economic consequences comparable to
those of the 1974 invasion we undertook
to implement substantial reforms which
allowed our economic reconstruction
sooner than even the most optimistic
expect
Asians now brief reference to the
positive results achieved by the Cyprus
economy rate in recently years justifies
a series of decisions that we took as
government and have achieved a number of
things I could say for example we exited
the economic adjustment program and even
sooner in fact than expected by the
international community we can also
mention the continuous upgrades by
rating agencies and the recession of
Cyprus into investment markets the
re-entry into international markets and
for the fourth consecutive year we have
noted a positive growth rate of close to
four percent unemployment is continually
on the decline and we have seen the
highest annual decrease in unemployment
among member states and finally for the
fifth consecutive year we expect to have
a surplus in our budget ladies and
gentlemen we are focused and we are
determined to maintain macroeconomic
stability and continue with the measures
under which a surplus or high growth
rates have been achieved and to give
further impetus impetus to the excellent
prospects that have been created with
regard to our major productive sectors
now with regard to the budget of the
European Union we are following the same
strategy the current negotiations on the
new MFF multi-annual financial framework
for 2021 to 2727 has to reflect the path
of growth that Europe has taken after a
very difficult decade as a result of the
global financial crisis we are aiming to
set an ambitious budget that will
include all the costs required to deal
with the modern challenges we have to
face together and these challenges cover
a broad spectrum of various priority
sectors such as the switch to digital
integration
promoting sustainable development
climate change innovation migration the
rise of extreme nationalism asymmetric
threats and the fight against terrorism
at the same time the new multi-annual
financial framework must focus on people
on European citizens and improving the
quality of their lives by rationalizing
expenditure and through proper planning
we have to ensure that the money that
belongs to the European taxpayer is
spent on targeted policies and in no
case is wasted and squandered on
inefficient programs the new budget
given that we will now be a Europe of 27
states needs to be suitably adapted but
also flexible and to maintain a balance
between our traditional policies and
modern needs moreover in that framework
of a closer economic conciliation we
need to seek to complete the venture of
the banking Union in the light of a
renewed monetary and economic union as
also the promotion of the capital
markets union which will mobilize
capital for investments in member states
mr. president undoubtedly the Common
Market which recently completed its 25th
birthday is one of the most important
goals achieved by the European Union the
long-term goal of defending the common
market Archy requires all necessary
measures to be taken to bring it into
line with new circumstances as they have
been shaped to respond fully to the
modern needs of the digital age to the
challenge of the low energy footprint of
the cyclical economy with a circular
economy
and above all to have a positive impact
on the daily lives of its citizens I
look forward to tomorrow's debate on
these issues during the work of the
European Council and from which I expect
a strong commitment to a strengthened
Common Market of the future ladies and
gentlemen moving from a soft power to
the common defense of the Union the fact
is that very much has been achieved as a
consequence of the Lisbon Treaty of
course there is room for further
improvement but always in a climate of
consensus and respect for the particular
sensitivities of each member state I
believe that a possible motive vacation
in the way decisions are taken in the
sector of defense would be
counterproductive to achieving the
convergence that is essential Cyprus has
and continues to be a supporter of the
defense and military cooperation which
is continuously developing among member
states we are among the countries that
from the very outset express their
desire to be part of pesco the permanent
structured cooperation although we
recognize pesco as a decisive step we
have a vision which is Europe's military
independence the creation of European
Armour a powerful factor a strong factor
to protect the borders of the Union and
I wish to underline that it must always
work not in an offensive but in a
defensive and a deterrent manner and
working towards the interests of the
Union remains our vision
mr. president ladies and gentlemen I
would now like to refer to a number of
external factors that in fact are a
threat to the cohesion of the European
Union these are factors that I believe
need to be dealt with decisively in an
environment of unity and solidarity the
unprecedented humanitarian crisis we've
been facing in recent years really means
that we need to put aside our different
approaches and narrow national
priorities the southern part of Europe
is facing mass flows of migrants and the
weight they have to bear is
disproportionate especially for those
member states in the front line my
country being one of those we are seeing
more and more migratory pressures that
we have to feel we have to bear and we
are therefore though one of those
countries that has the highest number of
migrants in proportion to its population
there are the reasons that accentuate
and exacerbate the problem on the one
hand the dividing line between the free
areas and the occupied areas in my
country and on the other hand the
continuing refusal of Turkey not only to
recognize the Republic of Cyprus but
also to implement the agreements that is
entered into with the European Union
such as the readmission agreement
doesn't even cooperate with the Cyprus
authorities because and this is a
candidate country I'm talking about it
feels that the Republic of Cyprus which
is a member state of the European Union
is actually not to be reckoned with
now with regard to the system we need to
revise the common European Asylum system
and the Dublin regulation to ensure
achievement of migration and refugees
among member states this is essential
ladies and gentlemen another challenge
we have to face is that of global
warming and climate change now we should
focus on the Paris agreement and also
take coordinated action aiming towards a
more ambitious policy in the framework
of the summit taking place in Katowice
in Poland if we underestimate the
visible dangers unfortunately the
consequences will be dire not only to
the ecosystem but to the economy as well
but also on everybody's everyday life in
the context of the broader regional role
we are developing and our trilateral
cooperation with countries in the region
we intend to play a coordinating role at
regional level to tackle the
consequences and impact of climate
change and relevant synergies will be
achieved with countries of the region
the eastern Mediterranean region is
among those regions where climate change
phenomena and the impact on the
environment of global warming have
really been felt very strongly mr.
president now at the major challenge in
this long history of the European Union
is of course the decision of the United
Kingdom to withdraw so for the first
time the 27 were called upon to manage
this venture of course we respect a
decision of the British people and that
was our only choice
as a European Union we negotiated in
seriousness and unity in supporting with
mr. buney a steam which prepared the
raft of principles that will allow us a
smooth exit of the UK from the Union and
I have to admit I am satisfied with the
overall result of the negotiations
we support a broad and multi-level
relationship between the UK and the EU
and we will continue to work towards
that aim the new relationship must be
mutually beneficial in full harmony with
the principles of the European Union its
structure and its autonomy with regard
to the British bases in Cyprus we are
also satisfied since we achieved our
initial target and that is the
unobstructed continuation of the
implementation of the community a key so
that all European citizens who reside or
work in the basis the UK basis will
continue to be able to enjoy their
rights and benefits as members of the
European Union mr. president
and gentlemen as Cyprus we wish through
our actions to make our contribution
towards a powerful United European Union
that promotes peace stability security
solidarity and prosperity of the peoples
that make up this unique mosaic and in
this context by using our geographical
location and our excellent relations
with our neighboring peoples during the
last years we have been working on
actions and synergies in the eastern
Mediterranean area which is an unstable
area we have set up with Greece
trilateral mechanisms of cooperation
with countries in the area such as Egypt
Israel Jordan Lebanon and Palestine on
the basis of international law and the
values and principles of mutual respect
and solidarity following a suggestion of
the government of Cyprus our proposal
was approved for the establishment of a
permanent trilateral Secretariat based
in Cyprus so that we can be more
effective in our coordination and also
so that we can continuously follow-up
and evaluate the course of this
cooperation establishing this trilateral
cooperation has proven to be very very
beneficial for the European Union
particularly in the field of energy
contributing to the much desired energy
security and the diversification of the
sources of energy and the energy
corridors of the European Union it's
important to bear in mind that the EU is
clearly showing solidarity with the
Republic of Cyprus in terms of its right
to exercise sovereign rights to explore
and exploit its natural sources in the
exclusive economic zone and we have seen
that we are supported in pointing out
the need to avoid any threats
or actions that may destabilize and may
not be competitive but compatible with
international law and the community aqui
ladies and gentlemen in my introductory
remarks I pointed out that when Cyprus
joined the EU it identified with all the
other European citizens we were looking
forward to an accession that would have
a catalytic role and bestow on the
citizens of Cyprus the same rights and
same level of respect of fundamental
freedoms and freedoms as those enjoyed
by the rest of the European citizens in
their own countries without any divisive
lines without intervention rights or
guarantor rights by third parties
without an occupying army and without
restrictions to the basic freedoms very
often I talk about my vision for a
Cyprus which is a beacon of stability in
the area of the Mediterranean the
eastern Mediterranean to speak
realistically we do know that the light
of that beacon falls far short of its
full potential as long as Cyprus remains
divided sometimes current challenges
make us forget important historical
truths but the Cyprus question basically
remains a problem of foreign invasion
occupation and violation of human rights
and fundamental freedoms because since
1974 more than a third of the population
of Cyprus has been forced to be refugees
in their own homeland at a time when the
Union is negotiating how it is going to
tackle new tragic wars resulting in
millions of refugees the refugees of
Cyprus continue to be deprived of their
basic freedoms and are not able to enjoy
peacefully their own properties
and to live in their own homes as is
their right while we are discussing the
future of Europe for the citizens of
Cyprus these four basic freedoms which
are self-evident for the rest of Europe
are still a far off target that has yet
to be achieved the president and members
of the Committee on petitions of the
European Parliament how are fully aware
of the realities on the ground and I'd
like to express at this point on behalf
of all Cypriots our thanks and our
satisfaction with the response of that
committee and the actions just taken
particularly with regard to the fenced
off city of virosa I cannot but agree
with the conclusions of the report
especially the reference to the fact
that the return of Russia to its lawful
residents would constitute the ideal
confidence-building measure a model of
coexistence and cooperation between
Greek Cypriots and Turkish Cypriots an
excellent forerunner if you will of the
comprehensive solution I may remind you
that in 1984 and in 1992 the
international community via the United
Nations Security Council and its
resolutions five five zero and seven
eight-nine called for the transfer of
the administration of that particular
area which is relying under Turkish
occupation that it should be transferred
to the responsibility of the United
Nations unfortunately that has not been
possible because of anchors stance mr.
president ladies and gentlemen Europe
which rightly takes part actively and
takes initiative to solve international
problems feels it has a moral duty to
help contribute towards resolving the
problem of a member state and a problem
which is in fact an open
and in its own body healing this wound
will reinforce and strengthen the Union
not just morally but substantially as
well because only then will Cyprus be in
a position to play to its full potential
its own crucial role in a very important
area in terms of the interests of the
European Union I wish to reassure the
members of the European Parliament that
I am determined to work tirelessly to
achieve a solution that will not create
winners and will not leave behind losers
a solution that will fully respect the
expectations and concerns of both Greek
and Turkish Cypriots it will create a
functional and viable federal state on
the basis of the UN Security Council
resolutions on the basis of agreements
between the leaders of the two
communities estates that is fully
sovereign and independent free of
dependence of any kind on third parties
through interventional rights or rights
of guarantee or occupation Army's a
European state whose structure
institutions and functions will be fully
compatible with the principles and
values of the European Union this is why
we support in every way the efforts of
the UN Secretary General and his special
envoy in the hope that the talks will
recommence very soon so that we will be
able to sit around the negotiating table
and work on an agreed framework in terms
of reference aiming towards achieving
the comprehensive solution and a
reunification of the island ladies and
gentlemen it would be an inexcusable
admission if with this opportunity given
me today I did not express the grateful
thanks of the people of Cyprus Greek and
Turkish Cypriots to all
the European Parliament for the
unrelenting support in our efforts in
trying to find a peaceful solution in a
European state mr. president ladies and
gentlemen in conclusion I would like to
thank you once again for giving me this
opportunity to present to you my vision
for the future of Europe we in Cyprus
this is the way we see the European
Union there are many challenges and
justifiably our expectations are high
however all the necessary ingredients
and guarantees are there as long as we
remain together United in solidarity and
respect for the basic values of the
European Union we continue with the
initial vision of a strong and
prosperous Europe not only in order to
preserve our precious mosaic but to
further enhance it and it is for this
prosperous Europe that we must join
forces
putting aside different approaches a
national interests that are narrow in
order to be able to deal effectively
with our common challenges this is the
only way that we will achieve a brighter
future for Europe and its citizens thank
you
[Applause]
ste amo their cue today we're about to
close the register for speaks under
country our procedure anyone wishing to
speak should it ask now or forever hold
your peace you need to hold up the form
and make sure that you're counted if he
was to be included on the list right at
this point I shall give the floor to mr.
Katainen the vice president of the
Commission present-day Ani present
Anastasiadis one of our members our
thoughts and hearts are with the victims
of last night's horrible attack against
humanity that we condemned with create
firms we are grateful for the tireless
work of the first responders and we
trust in the work of the law enforcement
services to bring those responsible to
justice
we will continue to defend our free and
open societies by all means in our use
the city of Strasburg is a symbol of
European peace and democracy values that
we will always defend the European
Commission stands alongside France and
French people at this very difficult
moment
remember members I wished we would have
had a better situation to talk about the
future in the future of Europe than
where we are today
nevertheless we cannot give up we need
to continue building better and save
Europe for our citizens intolerance and
hate don't belong to our societies and
they don't represent our values
I want to thank mr. president my good
friend Nichols for being here today to
debate the future of Europe I remember
when we talked about the future of EU in
the Prime Minister's office in Finland
many years back we have continued this
discussion during all these years and
now we are here in the European
Parliament to discuss with honourable
members on the challenges opportunities
and directions direction of the European
Union mr. president you and your country
has always shown the create European
solidarity you have shown this time and
again over the years when it comes to
migration you have always been there and
taking much more than your fair share of
responsibility the financial and
economic crisis also hit Cyprus harder
than the most the effects will not go
away overnight but today I see a
recovering labor market and economy
growing by over 4 percent in 2017 and
continuing at an impressive rate this
year I see a more stable financial
sector with the lower auto is still too
high rate of non-performing loans I see
also investment returning thanks in part
to the Juncker plan which has helped
trigger 109 million euro of additional
investment it'll also supported 124
smaller companies or startups to grow
and create jobs locally I will visit
Cyprus at the end of January to discuss
further use of younger plant in order to
help to boost growth and job creation
but if the situation has turned around
either it is because of the strength and
hard work of secret people I want to pay
tribute to them in particular for
everything they have done
I also want to pay tribute to you mr.
president the only cause for your
commitment to the program of recovery
tough decisions made and the commitment
to making them work should never be
overlooked by anyone in Europe we know
there's still a long way to go and the
Commission will assist you every step of
the way including through tailored
support offered by a structural reform
support service it has already provided
520 million EUR to support economic
integration of the island and improve
links and contact between its two
communities but it is also it also
continues to support Cyprus across the
port including me its climate and energy
caucus
the point is that as we look our future
Europe will stand in solidarity with
Cyprus just as Cyprus has always stood
in solidarity with Europe and nowhere is
that more important than when it comes
to bring then end the division of the
island Commission will stand ready to
assist any efforts Commission will
always answer your call to support any
negotiations or discussions held under
the auspices of United Nations that work
towards a fair comprehensive and viable
settlement this will be beneficial for
Cyprus for Europe and for the wider
security and stability in the region
there would be no more important message
for our common future but we must
prepare that future as of today later
this week European leaders including the
president will have a real discussion on
on our future long-term budget this is
about this is not about numbers or
figures only it's about our future
it is about deciding what Europe suit to
achieve and it is about deciding where
to invest in our future on the issues
that mattered most to the people of
Cyprus and the whole of Europe this is
why the Commission has put forward a
fair modern imbalanced budget a budget
that is more efficient and more focused
on the issues that matter to most just
as Cyprus has along long been calling
forth for instance there will be an
almost three-fold increase in funding
for my creation and security to make
sure that Europe can protect its
citizens this will be especially
important for Cyprus as a country that
has taken so much responsibility in this
area
funding for research and innovation will
be increased by 50% we have also
proposed to double the means of erasmus+
and new digital Europe program worth
nine billion euro will support Europe's
digital transformation all of these will
provide real opportunities for Cypriots
and to further boost the productivity of
Cypriot economy we have also proposed an
enhanced reform support programme with
22 billion euro earmarked for key
reforms identified in the European
semester all of this will make a real
difference on the crown in Cyprus and
across our Union so it is crucially
important that we can agree on our new
budget as swiftly as possible mr.
president
I count on your support your count about
support and of course this house house
support in order to make all this happen
thank you very much
mr. Cattani now he named a European
people party mounted the Weber president
in Zagat represent president the
president Anastasiades terrible night is
behind us now I'd like to say thank you
president Ione to you for the